black could simply win a pawn so yeah  big decision for nakamura will he go for  the draw will he allow the draw at least  or will he burn his bridges okay yeah i  would go for the draw david what about  you  take the risk if i'm playing magnus  draw's not too bad  and yeah hikaru has decided to repeat  the position  and now it is crunch time if he steps  back with the king  then the game will have well the  position will have repeated itself three  times and the game will be  declared draw and if hikaru  wants to roll the dice and amp up the  risk  value the risk levels then of course he  has to move his king  look at his body language he makes the  move as he's about to turn away and  there it is more checks and a draw we do  have a second draw in the final between  hikaru nakamura  and magnus crossing the quicker one this  time  but they are all tied in the match  the first match in the fight